foreign
[Music]
up on FYI we hit the catwalk to check
out the latest in sustainable fashion
[Music]
and I speak to the 13 year old Ukrainian
Refugee who's turned her experiences
into a novel I think it will help to
people realize what voice should it ask
[Music]
hello this is your Weekly News show FYI
where we give you the latest on all the
top stories well can you spot a fake
story from a real one well check out
these viral images that have been doing
the rounds online and tell us what you
think
these super cute creatures are
supposedly rare white bats that look a
little bit like Pomeranian dogs with
wings
and this picture is meant to be of a
type of plant called a duck Orchid but
are these real or just fake news
find out later
now you may have seen that it was World
Refugee day recently a day to celebrate
the strength and courage of displaced
people forced to leave their homes
because of War famine and Terror yeah it
was started by the United Nations which
is a global organization that brings
countries together to agree on and talk
about world issues
and this year I was part of the great
big live assembly my name's Scarlet and
I'm a journalist for the children's news
program FYI a special school assembly
where thousands of pupils across the UK
watched a live broadcast from a Syrian
refugee camp in Jordan
some of the people's got to talk to
children in the refugee camp to get a
better understanding of what life is
like for them yeah I mean that's really
interesting actually because I went to
that refugee camp myself last year and
it was a real eye-opening experience to
be honest with you I mean no one should
have to live in them conditions never
mind children yeah well the film you
made was actually shown as part of the
Great Big Life Assembly and I've been
speaking to pupils at Bracken Hill
School in bracknell who took part to
hear their thoughts on how they found it
what did you learn from the Great Big
Life Assembly how hard it is for the
refugees to move from one country that
they know to a different country that
they have no clue about I knew about
refugees but I never knew about like how
they live once again to like a refugee
camp I never knew that like people are
suffering so much in camps and it's very
important kind of to learn about people
because you never know what someone's
going through I loved it when they
showed how much they progressed with
just a few materials it gave me hope it
it taught me that even if things are
down there's always some how you can
rebuild they still have education I
didn't expect them to have like that
sort of stuff over there and they had
like all the little shops on the corner
and like how long they were and all
cramped like the little houses and shops
were together the major thing I learned
was how that kind of poor these
conditions are is sort of like
enlightens you to how these people
really have to live I saw one of the
houses had like metal sheets and the
outside it made me think of my house and
how you know we have bricks outside in
solution how everyone was quite cramped
into one space I found it quite shocking
it makes you really think about
everything you take for granted even
your house it's just something in our
lives where we think we will have like
everyone in the world it kind of just
enlightens you to the fact that not
everyone is as lucky as you it made me
feel bad for these people who they've
had to go from one place to another yeah
with nothing no one that's supposed to
be the bare minimum just like being able
to live in a country where you feel safe
and again some people don't have that so
that's really important
if we ever need a reminder about what
many refugees have to go through then
this last week has given us that with a
terrible tragedy in the Mediterranean a
boat carrying hundreds of migrants and
refugees from Libya to Italy capsized
off the coast of Greece with many people
losing their lives or still missing so
why are people still continuing to leave
their home countries and make these
sorts of Journeys if they're so
life-threatening one if you just don't
get it don't worry because Arvin has
been investigating
thank you
you know what they say there's no place
like home but imagine just for a moment
that your home was no longer safer and
you had to live somewhere like this
instead it could be because of war or
your family has been badly treated
because of your beliefs
or even climate change which can cause
severe droughts and floods when this
happens and families are forced to flee
their homes to seek shelter in a
different country they become refugees
I speak from experience because I am a
refugee
this is me in a refugee camp in Calais
in France a small tent was our home for
many months
me and my family had to leave my home
country of Iran because our lives were
in danger
we traveled thousands of miles each
country we got to forced us to leave and
go to the next one until we finally
reached the French Coast
more and my story later firstly how many
refugees are there like me
look at this across the world there are
currently over 32 million refugees
nearly 40 million of them are children
it's the biggest mass movement of people
since the second world war when millions
of people fled their homes to find
somewhere safe to live in fact the
United Nations says every minute of
every day an average of 25 people are
forced to flee their homes
more than seven out of every 10 refugees
come from just five countries
There Are Places hit by war and violence
like Syria Afghanistan and South Sudan
and most recently Ukraine and then
extreme poverty has driven millions of
people out of Venezuela
so where do all these refugees go
well most of them end up in these three
countries right next to where they came
from
so can you guess which country looks
after the most refugees
the answer is turkey with 3.7 million
refugees while Colombia has 2.5 million
and Germany has 2.2 million most of the
refugees live in towns and cities or
refugee camps where the conditions can
get cramped and overcrowded
some refugee camps are as big as cities
but not everyone is happy about their
country taking in refugees check out
these UK newspaper headlines from the
last few years
some people believe we already have too
many refugees here and there isn't
enough space for anyone else
others say refugees should be made
welcome here and given our support to
rebuild their lives in fact thousands of
British families signed up to host
ukrainians
whatever you think there are still
hundreds of people who risk their lives
to come to Britain every year like me
the UK was our final hope we left the
refugee camp in France and with the help
of people Smugglers we had no choice but
to cross the English Channel on a small
boat it was terrifying eventually the
government accepted my family was in
danger in Iran and we are so grateful we
have been allowed to make a new life in
the UK
I've learned to speak English and I have
a great School
some politicians are calling for
stricter patrols to try and stop people
coming here in small boats My Hope Is
that more can be done to help people
like me the moment we step foot in
Europe if you need a reminder by the
skill of the problem then how about this
just in the time you've been watching
this somewhere in the world about a
hundred people will have been forced to
flee their homes
[Music]
another person who knows exactly what
it's like to be forced to leave their
home is 13 year old Ukrainian Refugee
yayva I went to meet her to find out
more
the beginning
horror War the fear in my eyes
yeva is a Ukrainian Refugee who fled her
home city of harkiv after Russia invaded
Ukraine
she now lives in Dublin and has written
a book about her experiences called you
don't know what war is
all of a sudden a massive rocket sped by
and exploded with such force that I felt
my heart going cold in my chest
why did you decide to write a book when
I decided to write it out it wasn't I
wasn't expecting that it would be a book
um I thought it would be like maybe
um like a story maybe about myself I
wanted to express all my feelings into
the onto the paper and like I really
wanted after 10 20 years I'll be able to
read and maybe my future children will
ask how war was it like in Ukraine so
able to give them diary and they were
able to read this yeah it's amazing that
you know you just start off by writing a
diary and it's become a whole book
that's been published so what was the
process of writing the book
I decided just to learn everything that
happened to me everything that I'm
feeling and this is you know like such
painful situations where our apartments
are bumped I was just describing our
journey through Ukraine and through the
Europe and then eventually when we
settled in Ireland
[Music]
he's been settling into her new life in
Ireland
the impact of war is still on her mind
so do you think that your book is going
to help others who are struggling
um I think it will help to people
realize what voice should it us and it
destroys families and children and I
really want everybody who understands we
don't need a war we should have peace in
every single part of the world
see you guys are into your fashion right
yeah and I do love my Chinese
particularly definitely when I'm not in
my uniform well have you heard of the
latest craze of junk Couture now if you
think I'm talking about things you'd
find in the bin then you're right
John Couture is the world's largest
youth sustainable fashion competition
challenging pupils on schools across the
world to create imaginative and pretty
often wacky outfits out of nothing but
upcycled and recycled materials
and two experts in the world of junk
Couture Leyland Zara join us now
[Music]
wow I mean you guys look amazing can you
tell us a bit about your outfits or our
outfits were made for the dunk tour
World Finals last year and they're all
inspired by lots of different things for
example this one's inspired by 1950s
ball gowns this was like the polar
opposite it's all like sweets and Candy
just pink and fun so what are they made
of I mean this one it looks like a
wedding dress it looks amazing so is
this an umbrella uh yes it's like a
parasol that we made out of coat hangers
that we tied together as well as old
plastic bags the skirt is mainly made
out of old dry cleaning bags because my
family did a lot of dry cleaning it's
better than you know putting it in the
bin so what's on yours it's made of a
ton of different things it's like a
repurposed dress mattress topper
obviously a lot of Lindor wrappers
loofers and then paper and you say it's
all recycled materials right I mean so
it's friendly fashion isn't it yeah
definitely all of our materials that
we've used have been repurposed you
can't use anything that's new so how did
you guys get involved
we first started because our school set
off a club for it because it's been
going on in Ireland for about 12 or 13
years but they just introduced it into a
ton of different countries like
um Italy France obviously of the UK so
our school decided to sign up for it and
then
we just continued until we got to the
world final how long did it take you to
make your outfits well this um one took
around five months to make whereas this
one was a lot quicker it was about four
weeks but we did that one at school and
this one was at home right after we'd
finished the other world final so we got
straight back to work so you guys said
that you took part in the last World
final so what's the atmosphere like at
the competitions it's absolutely amazing
atmosphere like we have so many
different people from all over the world
coming together and it's just a really
fun atmosphere and we're obviously so
excited for the junk Couture World
Finals this year it's coming off in
October in Wembley so we're really
hoping that more people can see it and
join in definitely again your outfits
look fabulous thank you guys so much for
joining me thank you thank you
hello
so did you think that these viral
pictures of some white bats and a plant
called the dark orchids were real well
they're both fake the bats are actually
stuffed White backdoors and the duck
Orchid was created using artificial
intelligence technology
well that's nearly it for this week but
don't forget you can catch up on all our
episodes of FYI on our webpage at
first.news forward slash FYI as it was
insect week this week we're going to
leave you with some incredible
photographs of some fabulous insects
taken by amateur photographers across
the world as part of a competition see
you next time bye
[Music]
thank you